محاولات للحسم السريع والسيطره كامله باءت
بالفشل من قبل الطرفين لينتهي الشهر الاول
من الاشتباكات بتقاسم السيطره حتى اللحظه
المواجهات المسلحه لا تتزال تتركز فيها
الخرطوم وبحر واندرمان لثقالها السياسي
بالنسبه للطرفين واحتوائها على مواقع
حيويه واستراتيجيه ومقر حكوميه خريطه
السيطره الحاليه قوات الدعم السريع تسيطر
على 80% من مدن الخرطوم وفق تقارير صحفيه
حيث تنتشر بالقصر الجمهوري ومحيط القياده
العامه للجيش ومطار الخرطوم الدولي وسط
استمرار للمعارك في هذه النقاط كما توجد
ايضا مجاميع عربات الدعم السريع العسكريه
بمصفاه الجيلي للبترول ومحطه المياه
الرئيسيه بمدينه بحري عند هذه النقطه
وايضا مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون الرسمي
باندرمان عند هذه النقطه اشكاليه الجيش
الان في العاصمه تتمثل بصعوبه نشره طبعا
البريه التي تعرضت اكثر من مره للضرب
وتشتت قبل وصولها الى الخرطوم فيما نشاطه
الجوي مستمر بهدف قطع طرق امداد قوات
الدعم السريع حرب الجسور العشره ايضا
محتدمه ويسيطر الجيش على جسور الحلفايه
وايضا جسر النيل الابيض والانقاذ وكوبر
والمنشيه الابيض فيما تفرط قوات الدعم
السريع تفرض سيطره على جسور شامبات وتوتي
وايضا سوبا في ممك النمر تسيطر عليه كل
جهه من كل طرف من كل جهه افضليه مؤقته
للجيش في الجسور وسيطر على كل عواصم
الولايات السودانيه عدا ولايات دارفور
الخمس وايضا العاصمه الخرطوم هناك ايضا
خلفيه لامداد قوات الدعم السريع فيما اذا
ذهبنا غربا تعتبر مدينه بورتسودان هذه
المدينه المطله على البحر الاحمر بمثابه
الرئه وايضا المتنفس الاساسي لنظام
الخرطوم وتمده بالعتاد والعتيد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات